各位曲博科技教师的观众朋友大家好我是曲博
今天是星期四晚上我们科技问答的时间
喜欢我们的节目
记得替我们按赞订阅分享开启小铃铛
那么首先呢我们还是要诈骗市井
曲博所有的YouTube Facebook跟LINE社群平台
都不会和大家私下谈论个股的股价
更不会和大家推荐个股投资
如果大家收到任何陌生人传送讯息
关心股票操作或者推荐个股
那个都是诈骗集团
请大家不用客气替我卷取他
请大家告诉大家
感谢大家的协助
那么首先我们来一点广告时间
工商时间
科技启程智慧未来
各位知道我有在政治大学的科技管理
智慧财产研究所教书
这个是116年的招生说明会
政大科治所基本就是
结合科技管理跟智慧财产相关的课程
这边的QR Code有招生的网页
IG的粉专跟脸书的粉专
各位可以扫描QR Code来参考
各位先参加说明会
那了解到底这个科系呢
有哪些相关的课程还有老师
那另外还有一件事情
我刚刚突然想起来
这个我们知识力的网站呢
即将要上线了
那一直都缺这个工程方面的
对网站架设非常熟悉的工程师
所以我创业的时候呢
一直都缺一位对于网站的前后台都很熟悉
可以带人的工程师
应该是工程主管
那大家如果本身呢
对这个网页相关的这个程式设计
包含前台后台资料库
都很有经验的话
欢迎大家留言或者是写信
各位可以直接留言在影片的下面
那如果有机会的话
我想可以找到一个比较资深的人来
协助我们把这个网站建立起来
政大的招生说明会
他主要就是招收这个科技管理组
主要就是文法商理工农
以各种不同领域的都可以来
加入科技管理那再来是这个智慧财产组他主要是有法律的背景专研法律相关的知识那更重要的是需要这个
智慧财产权所以需要
法律知识也需要工程的知识
所以如果你是非法律背景的基本上也可以
那我刚刚讲到的这个
说明会有9月3号
线上的
说明会
报名网址在这边我待会贴在影片下面
那9月22号呢是晚上
在政治大学的一仙楼101教室
这个是实体的
那接下来我们回答一下上个礼拜网友的问题
那上一次有人问到说
举伯认为大家现在围绕在玻璃机板
矽光子还有电池备用单元
BB这些话题
还有什么地方是大家很少讨论的
但却是人工智慧基础建设很重要的一部分
你这边还少写了一个就是电
我各位知道现在缺电是一个问题
不过这个大家也讨论很多了
那坦白说
我想了很久
我还真没想出有什么是
这个人工智慧基础建设
还没有讨论到的
那前一阵子很热门的题目就是
马斯克要把资料中心放在外太空
这个马斯克只是随便说一说
但是呢
台湾的厂商很认真
我知道
据我所知就有好几个公司
在公司内部都成立了
一个组织专门研究跟这个
低轨道卫星
建置资料中心有关的技术的可行性
所以看起来大家都很认真的
但坦白说那个难度很高
非常多问题需要解决
那除了这个之外呢
坦白讲我还真想不出还有什么东西
那总之呢这个人工智慧有六大趋势
各位特别注意这个2026年刚好是一个
转捩点前面10年就是2015到2025
后面的10年是2026到2035
整个转变有6个趋势
第一个就是以训练为主
会转向推论越来越重要
大家要记得训练是烧钱
推论是赚钱
所以对云端服务供应商来说
推论才是他们赚钱的重点
第二个是以云端的运算为主
转向终端加速越来越重要
换句话说我们的手机
我们的电脑内建人工智慧的加速器做终端的推论运算越来越重要那第三个是以图形处理器为主转向人工智慧的加速器越来越重要各位知道
辉达过去是在卖这个图形处理器GPU
可是呢今年的Computex
辉达呢就投资这个Glock
就推出了所谓的语言处理器LPU
它就是一个人工智慧加速器
所以呢
因为推论运算用加速器的效果
更好
黄仁勋执行长很了解这一点
所以呢
他才会去投那个Glog
那么第四个
是
以动态随机存取记忆体DDR
或者HBM为主
转向快散记忆体SSD越来越重要
各位看过我节目都知道
现在记忆体厂商开始在推所谓的HBF
高频宽快散记忆体
甚至使用快散记忆体做成固态硬碟机
然后透过
增加控制晶片的存取速度
来取代这个高频宽记忆体
这个都是很重要的趋势
那第五个是以电通讯为主
转向光通讯越来越重要
这个就是你讲的细光子
不过呢
这一个光通讯呢
未来会慢慢走向晶片跟晶片之间
用光通讯
这个是我认为没那么快
但是2030年以后呢
应该就会有一些实际的案例
那第六个这个
大家可能比较少听
我补充的就是
以电运算为主
转向光运算越来越重要
各位知道
光运算叫光脑
Optical Computer
这个东西在50年前
科学家就讨论过
但是讨论一阵子发现
可行性很低
各位记得这个电运算就是用开关
代表0跟1
那光运算是用光的亮暗代表0跟1
那
一样运算的过程就是用量按量按去控制
那这个东西不可行
可是呢最近这几年开始科学家发现
人工智慧的推论运算
如果用光运算的话
更省电而且速度更快
所以开始有一些新创公司
在做所谓人工智慧的光运算
那这个东西我认为要成熟没那么快
我个人认为也是2030年以后
才有机会成熟
但是如果他确实证明是可行的那这会是一个蛮特别而且很重要的变化那这个部分还要观察我目前还说不准
那根据我对这个光运算
有看过一些相关的资料
包含一些论文期刊
有一些方法确实看起来是可行的
只不过要靠时间验证
所以需要给他们一两年的时间
让他们验证这个可行性
总之这个各位要特别留意
这个
是一个值得大家留意的一个方向
再来网友问到这个ChatGPT在训练人工智慧做网路攻击的时候
发生了什么事
那我去查了一下这是最近发生的事
2026年7月OpenAI旗下没有公开的一个人工智慧代理
在进行内部网路能力测试的时候
他没想到这一个人工智慧代理
我们常讲其实那个东西不可靠
不牢靠
他竟然自己连上网路
并且对hugging face发动漏洞相关的串联攻击
结果这个hugging face是后来自己发现
OpenAI他这一个人工智慧代理的行为
有点类似红队测试
就是去冒充駭客
用各种方法去测试系统的漏洞
本来这个测试应该在可控范围
但是结果AI呢
自己跑到网路上去攻击别人
这件事就有点捞过戒
所以呢这个等于是失控了
那更糟糕的事情是发生这件事之后
OpenAI也没有主动通知人家
所以这边就谈到企业诚信
那后来是什么事情呢
后来这个
攻击是在5 6月的时候
就在OpenAI内部演练的时候
有留下这个记忆残留
但是到了7月中旬
Hugging Face检测到异常
去检查
顺藤摸瓜溯源
才发现原来这件事是OpenAI干的
最后双方才在7月21号公开
联合发表声明
那这个东西其实就会有一些问题
就是今天你做了这个事
就你没有主动去公开通知人家
反而是被人家抓到
找出来了才跳出来
发表声明了
这个是第二个问题
总之呢
这个被溯源才承认
就是被人家抓到了才承认啊
这确实是不太好了
但他原来的想法应该是想说
如果没被杀到这件事就算了
大概是这样
那总之人工智慧
会的攻击
这个是现在治安一个很重要的题目
那另外一个重点就是人工智慧代理
基本上我认为是
仍然有很多的漏洞
等于是说可信度还有很大的问题
这还需要时间
那再来网友问到这个
先发电光跟联雅的差别
我们大概看一下
我想联雅光电
他是做这个累晶元
所以各位看有这个
分布回收雷射用的累晶元
那再来就是这个
EML
这应该是外部调变雷射
或者是电质吸收调变雷射
所使用的这个累晶元
那还有这个APD这个是
雪崩光二极体就是光侦测器用的
累晶元
那还有这个PHABI PRO雷射用的累晶元
这是最普通的雷射
还有这个PIN的光侦测器用的雷晶元
所以联雅光电基本就是做雷晶元
那他的这个因为人工智慧需求
所以最近呢
他的这个需求越来越大
那针对制药中心呢
他有做
刚刚说的分布回收雷射
然后有VIXO
垂直共振枪面色型雷射的雷晶元
还有连续波长雷射的雷晶元
高功率的
然后有细光子的雷晶元
然后再来就是
深化加光侦测器的雷晶元
那还有一些是消费性电子产品用的雷晶元
当然也是发光元件
所以很纯他就是做雷晶元
那先发电光呢稍微有点不同
那他的制药中心也是做连续波长雷射
但是呢他的连续波长雷射看起来也是AP
Wafer
Apple Texte Wafers
就是也是累晶源
那他没有介绍细节
所以我也不知道他是不是有做
他还写晶片
所以他晶片的意思
不确定他的什么意思
但是看起来累晶源是确定的
那另外他比较特别
他有这个Micro 3D TX技术
这个是在做
发光二极体的光通讯
这个叫Optical Engine
那基本呢就是频宽
可以到每一公尺一个Tera BPS
功耗可以低到一个bit只要一个picojower这个就是我们之前说在电子机体线路呢放驱动器跟转阻放大器然后上面的这一个
把这个光侦测器的阵列跟
发光二极体的阵列呢
把它粘到这个晶片上
那各位注意
这一个是用细做的
这一个是用化合物半导体
所以只能用封装的方式叠起来
他的目的呢就是在处理器
跟记忆体之间利用
micro led 跟
光纤来传输讯号
或者处理器跟处理器之间用micro led 跟
光纤来传动传递讯号
那他把这个技术叫micro 3D
tx
那实际上呢各位记得这个
led 这种东西
他的色散比较严重
所以呢他没有办法
有非常好的資料傳輸率
各位知道雷射
現在的資料傳輸率至少都是100Gbps起跳
在資料中心裡面用的都是高速的
那最快可以做到200Gbps
但是聽說還沒有量產或者量產不多
大部分是sample樣品
但是MicroLED因為會射散
所以呢他的資料速率大概就是1Gbps
或者2Gbps
大概是雷射的1%
如果一顆microLED資料速率只有1Gbps
那你要做到100Gbps就只能用100個
microLED100條光線
所以各位看哦
10x10就是100
所以呢這樣一個陣列就是100Gbps
上面用這個micro lens
好
微透鏡聚光
下面用這個細中介板
所以這個
先發電光有這個MicroLED的解決方案
所以這個是它的封裝之後的照片
然後再來它有這個測試的結果
就是跟FAU連結起來之後的測試結果
你看這是MicroLED光源
發射之後
透過反射鏡反射
然後到這個receiver偵測器偵測
這是它偵測的結果
它看起來好像是用濾光
我知道的好像現在
Metal ID通訊用綠光的比較多
還有Vixel 他們也有這個Vixel 但是看起來也是 AP Waiver
也是累晶源有10G25 56Pen4 100G PAN4那比较有趣的是波长他的发光波长是850
各位记得这个垂直共振枪面射型雷射呢
目前主要都是用生化加
所以呢
发光的波长大概就在850或980
耐尼
那下面这边说有做到1060耐尼
这个应该是极限的
那波长再长的用零化音的
基本上Vixel现在呢
做的效果不好
所以应该是还没有人量场
大部分都是Sample
那另外他们家还有做Sensing感测器
那感测元件也是用Vixel
所以有850 940 905
这个都是生花家这一类的材料
所以这两间公司有部分竞争
我只能说这样子
但他们的东西并不完全一样
好那再来呢
这个网友问到
mcl 跟光通还有玻璃机板
一样是散热
必走的路吗
这个mcl 应该是指micro channel lead
这个就是所谓微通道盖板
我稍微解释一下
散热是非常重要
在人工智慧
因为处理器越来越热
那散热发展目前有三个阶段
第一个阶段就是传统的水冷板
那水冷板基本上呢就是一个
水冷板
裡面的通水
然後把這個水冷板跟封裝外殼接起來
水冷板的金屬表面跟封裝外殼的金屬表面
雖然看起來很平
但是裡面多多少少都有縫隙
所以如果你直接這樣
接觸疊起來的話那個熱散不出來的
那個縫隙怎麼填滿
就所謂的
散熱界面材料
或稱為導電膏
各位應該有用過導電膏
就是陶瓷粉
陶瓷會散熱
所以把陶瓷粉抹在封裝外殼
然后把这个随冷板靠上去
两个就会粘得紧
然后热就可以散出去
但不管怎么说
这个散热板都是在封装的外面
所以散热效果还是会有极限
所以第二个阶段
就会演进到所谓的Micro Channel Lead
就是你这边说的微通道盖板
那微通道盖板实际上就是把随冷板
缩小变成微米等级
通常是100微米左右
跟頭髮差不多
那很細了
再把這個縮小的微通道蓋板整合到先進封裝裡面去所以各位特别注意这个微通道盖板已经跟封装相关
所以做微通道盖板的厂商
通常要是跟这个封装厂合作
才有办法做这个东西
所以你问到说
这个光通讯还有玻璃机板
是一样是必走的路吗
我个人认为是
但是没那么快
我看到一个资料
我忘了是哪一间公司的法说会
他们董事长说
2027年明年
这个异能大概会占他们营收的一半
所以Roughly明年异能可能就会超过弃能
但是那个都是一般的随能版Copeland
这个微通道盖板现在已经有厂商在做了
但是这个东西要成熟还要时间
我认为至少还需要两年
所以大概是2028吧
才会比较有看到一个声音
然后到2030
才会有比较大的量
那我个人认为这个是必走的路没有错
那做这个东西的
基本上你这边问到的是一拳
那实际上我记得建策也有做
所以基本就是
他们竞争啊看他们各家各品本市
那基本的其实都是属于精密机械加工
只是你要加工到这个
微米的等级
那各位看这个一拳有做
易能散热方案
但是有没有各位看到这个
这个东西其实
显然这个
金属的加工然后呢做精密加工做散热
但是呢
他这边也没有提到微通道盖板
所以显然他们应该只是在研发阶段
我认为都有机会
跟建策竞争的
只是现阶段大家都不成熟
所以这个都还需要时间
那第三阶段又不一样
第三阶段呢
这个就更狠了
这个科学家想要把这个流体
直接通到细晶片的背面
各位知道
发热的是细晶片的正面
你直接从背面就把热带走
这个效果一定最好
这个是第三阶段
但是这个东西是2030年以后的事
才会看到一个样子
台积电有发表过论文
我的YouTube有曾经介绍过这个论文
所以我待會把它貼在下面
如果有興趣再自己看
總之這個
第一階段第二階段第三階段這個
技術路線是蠻明確的
那第一階段第二階段我認為是必然的
那第三階段這個
把液體直接通到晶片的背面
這個其實有非常多困難
這裡面包含那個通道太細
還有就是你這個液體
裡面要非常乾淨
如果你有一點 particle
大概就塞住了
所以这个问题太多了
短时间我认为不会成熟
这网友问群联为什么营收大爆发
这个潘建成董事长不是讲过很多次了吗
事实上群联制作flash
那我们刚刚也说这个未来
整个人工智慧会会从
dram转向flash越来越重要
主要是因为
推论运算需要储存大量的
这个所谓的见值快取
这个模型才不用一直重复运算
那各位想每一个推论的人
都需要储存大量的建制快取
那可想而知这个记忆体很大
那这种东西你用DRAM来存
太浪费了空间不够
所以业界的方向大概就是用Flash
那坦白说
群联其实做的是消费性电子相关
但是我猜他们家的SSD
有一些应该是跟伺服器
或者人工智慧伺服器相关
所以对群点来说有消费性电子的需求
有这个
SSD就是伺服器用的这个需求都有
那为什么营收大爆发没有为什么因为涨价啊
因为最近记忆体缺货啊
所以价格就越来越离谱啊
每一家都赚翻了啊
你去看看那个海力士那才离谱啊
赚翻了
就是涨价嘛
再来网友问到明年高阶同伯市场竞争者很多
市場缺口預估從缺三成變成缺一成
其實很正常啦
因為今年大家都在擴廠
擴廠擴大之後
難免就會發生這樣的現象
容科做電解銅箔
生產銅箔基板需要的關鍵原料
所以這算其中之一
HBM及
Law Alpha球系亞都
一家公司就享有全球80%的份额而连锐靠自研的火焰熔熔法异象合成技术目前在连锐
国内市占率28-30%
排第一全球也有15-20%
特别是在高界HPM晶片这一块
国内只有他量产
关键客户这个连锐通过三星海力士的龙头认证
也提供给
国内主要封装厂
实际上全球30%的HBM
晶片封装用料
他是做那个二氧化系的球嘛
然后那个均匀度要很
均匀然后放在我猜是HBM拿来做
spacer的
这个重点是
尺寸要一微米以下
然后呢要做到非常均匀
就每一颗要一样大小
各位有看到这个都是国外的公司
像这种东西
中国也有厂商
连锐啦
你想的是大陆的连锐心裁
主要当然是国外的厂商
那大陆也有公司
但是我没有听说台湾有人做
所以
各位要心里有数啊
这个材料这个工业
大陆做的比我们还好
这个真的是我们要好好检讨
对啊江苏连锐心裁
这个真的是我们要检讨
台湾只要讲到这个
真的不得不说两句
就是
台湾的厂商都比较短视近利
基本就是要赶快赚快钱
然后要做这种所谓基础的研发
几乎没有人想要
用心蹲下来做
这一点
台湾的公司做的比大陆还差
这个真的是
我们要好好检讨要好好努力
这个再来是全自动驾驶发展到哪里
老人
驾车容易车祸
车厂如果生产全自驾来卖
取代老人驾车应该很棒
是啊
全自駕有多棒你知道吗
开车的时候呢
你就可以做自己的事
完全不用理车子啊
问题是现在做的不好啊
那目前真正在
这个路上跑
已经确认全自駕的这种计程车
譬如说WIMO啦
譬如说那个
大陆有这个什么罗伯快跑啊
事实上
还很少还不多啦
嘿
所以这个还需要时间啊
我觉得
主要是我们的基础建设也不成熟不能配合
现在所有的基础建设都是
旧的东西
没有办法像交通号制没有办法主动发出讯号没有办法跟自驾车沟通那这些都需要通讯协定需要基础建设这个都要时间我认为没有花个十年是做不起来
但是目前的话
这个自驾计程车
或许就可以给老人
做就不会有问题
一般电脑用的记忆体和SSD
今年超贵
什么时候才改善
这个我认为
我昨天才去一个记忆体厂商演讲
他们
是说到明年看起来都还很缺
所以看起来今年是不可能的
到明年下半年
看有没有机会稍微好一点
教求有什么用
你是指塑教求吧
中科院研究出这个能做什么
北京正负电子对撞机上的北京浦仪3
国际合作小组完成
经过15年的研究
团队建立了教求存在完整实验链数据
解决困扰物理学界近半个世纪的难题
这种学术的东西
还真是我有没看过
我们来看一下
自然界中存在
纯粹由粒构成的全新物质形态
哇这个是学术研究
好吧这个我花时间研究一下
如果有特别的话呢
我们再来好好介绍一下
中国科学院
你看人家做这种基础研究
对啊这个台湾完全望尘莫及
好这个我花一点时间研究
这看起来不是那么容易理解
网友问到元太跟利基电
未来一到三年的趋势
这个元太的电子子现在是独占
所以这间公司非常有特色
那只是之前股价有修正
那最近好像又涨回来了
没有涨回到原来那么高
基本上我觉得这个公司是很有特色
只是说电子子
目前看起来他的市场
成长也是很确定
但似乎没有
像想象中的成长的这么
快速
所以各位看他最高炒到300块
那后来就修正到150
然后
到200现在又在修正
所以
看起来就是还需要一些时间
而且元泰现在几乎是独占
独占电子子
2026年第一季的 EPS 是2块
所以你看很明显就是没有想象成长那么多你看哦去年赚9块今年呢可能就十几块那十几块的话本益比算30倍就300块
20倍就200块
就他只有171
看起来是蛮委屈的
我觉得是这样啦
因为现在大家都在封AI
没有人在理店指指
这个市场就是这样
所以AI相关的股票本益比都非常高
那利基电基本上他的特色就是
记忆体最近缺货
所以这个对他是优势
那第二个重点是
利基电也在转型
他们开始在做细电容
先进封装用的被动元件
那因为他们是做记忆体
所以把电容挖深这件事
对他们来说比较容易
所以细电容就是要把电容挖深
所以这个确实适合他们
所以做记忆体
所以今年一月期应该是不错
那唯一的风险就是大陆
各位记得大陆的这个长江存储跟长新存储
是不是这两间他们主要开出来的记忆体
都是消费性电子的
这个跟立基电基本上是直接竞争
那短期还不会有影响
但是时间线拉长
我觉得这个可能会有压力
再来我们有硬能
是半导体先进封装设备厂
专门处理气泡翘躯残留物散热
这个技术门槛高吗
我这样说
他就是专门帮客户解决各种疑难杂症
他必须客制化
所以这是有一定的门槛
但是你硬要说非常高
坦白说也没有说非常高
重点就是你必须要非常专精
帮客户解决各种疑难杂症
而且要投入
那他这一点是做的不错
然后再加上他股本小
所以他的这个美股盈与EPS很高
主要是这样
那有没有竞争对手
我认为应该有类似的公司
但是我没有特别研究是谁
那技术上可能也跟他有一段落差
再来网友问到这个
目前光通讯的瓶颈雷射光源解决后
因应未来产业技术发展
產能最大的瓶頸可能輪到哪個部分
是玻璃原料還是光路結構
玻璃原料當然不會啊
那個玻璃是很便宜的東西
原料也是很
常見的東西
玻璃不會是瓶頸
那我認為未來的這個
瓶颈可能是
因为细光子跟共同封装光学
还有我们说过的光学中介版
就是用光去连接两个晶片
这个里面有光路结构的设计
有调变器
各位记得
光通讯有一种方法
是直接调变镭射
亮暗代表0跟1
但是更多时候为了增加调变速度
他们用的是调变器
Majulator
记得调变机就是控制亮暗的那个元件
那因为那个元件呢
在制作上有很多问题
而且要非常精细的制程
所以这个东西会是瓶颈
那关于这个呢
各位可以去参考我之前的影片
我之前有介绍那个Light Matter
各位看一下就知道
它里面有一些困难
在量子电脑的各个线路中
台湾是不是还是超导比较有优势
你要听实话吗
台湾没有优势
我们的量子电脑是落后人家一大截
那你要是问我说
目前台湾的这个研究单位做的
基本上超导是一个
那离止景也有人做
目前看起来是这两个比较有优势
但是那不是台湾的优势
台湾有人做而已
研究所推荐哪个老师吗
那要看你在哪个学校啦
台大电机系有做量子电脑
这是以前我们实验室的学弟非常优秀
他是台大电机系毕业
然后呢
这个硕士班跟博士班
在国外读书的回来的
各位有兴趣当然可以跟他聊聊
那另外这个张庆睿教授
这是物理系物理系也有很多老师啊
那也不是只有台大了
事实上那个
哎中原大学是不是
这个张庆瑞教授好像在中原大学
他有些学生在那边也有在做
所以我想这个要看是哪个学校
然后呢你要去查一下老师的专场
那你预计会申请物理相关
对啊没有错
这没有问题
但是觉得对实验比较没兴趣
不确定怎么往量子电脑发展對實驗沒興趣是什麼意思對實驗沒興趣不行啊那你只能做理论吗还是你数学比较强
量子电脑也需要啊
量子这个逻辑杂
这个还有量子演算法
这种东西就是数学啊
所以我不确定你实验没兴趣
是指你比较喜欢算数学吗
还是喜欢做模拟
这个都可以啊
所以我想没关系
你等这个比较确定是
哪个学校哪个科系
我们再看要怎么做
再来量子电脑心拳好像有做
其实有啦
但是那个跟国外比起来都差很多
我们那个只能说是研究而已
还算不上是真的量产的东西
好那再来
曲伯之前讲的二流画目基本没什么用
北京大学呢
有一篇Nature的论文就没有了
那二维芯片根本不成熟
北大复旦据说两年
已经量产两年多
但是都没有
起码20年才有成果
我稍微解释一下
这个中国大陆因为被美国
挡住了极止外观
所以呢
在缩小原件这件事呢
是没有办法做下去
当然他们还努力的在克服
那怎么办呢
他们学术界当然就开始在
進一步去做所謂的二維的電晶體
二維電晶體二流化木是目前大家認為有機會的材料
但是我個人認為
大陸去做那個東西沒有意義
因為那個是以後的事情
你不是做二維材料就好
你的元件還是要縮小
你沒有極子外光你還是不能縮小
所以基本上大陸做這個其實只是學術研究
台積電有極子外光所以它已經縮小了
那現在問題是要再縮小會遇到的問題
所以二流化木是其中一种可能
那我不否认二流化木这个东西到底能不能量产
这还是很大的问题
各位特别注意
这个二流化木不是直接长在细晶圆上
各位如果去看我这个这个礼拜二的影片
就会发现他是先把二流化木长在蓝宝石上
那为什么要这样做呢
这一定是跟金格匹配有关
也就是必须用蓝宝石才能长得出二流化木的单晶
那二流化木长好之后
他还要用一种特殊的制程把它转移到细晶圆上
然后各位想想看
蓝宝石现在最大的尺寸就6吋
好像有8吋的你8吋的晶圆蓝宝石长好二流化你把它转到细晶矽晶圓12吋啊那也不行啊所以你得要先解決藍寶石12吋的問題好
就算你解決了
各位記得二流化木是
一層原子這麼薄的東西
或者幾層原子這麼薄的東西
你請問你要怎麼把一個
12吋這麼薄的東西
拿起來然後移到矽晶圓上
他有一個特殊的製程
那那個製程呢
以后有机会我们再介绍
他是利用那个压克力数值
PMMA去做一个转移的动作
但是我跟各位说
那个东西我都很怀疑
在工厂能不能量场
那个在实验室可以做
因为实验室不在乎量率
你在工厂里面
你12寸整个移过去
只要有一个地方破掉
那个量率就掉下去了
所以基本上你这样的说法
其实是有道理的
但是你说基本没啥用
我觉得也不能这么说
这个学术上还是要有一些方法去克服
但是确实问题还很多
所以台积电这篇论文
其实就是炒炒股票而已
这个要真的量产
那还是很久以后的事
我跟各位说
这个二流化木的二维电晶体
可能还不是2030
搞不好是2035年以后的事
所以还早至少还10年
群传有大家有转型吗
当然有啊当然有啊
我觉得群创的转型做的很成功啊
他的转成这个先进的封装
像友达也是
他们也转向先进封装啊
这个我觉得方向是对的啊
那公司本来这个净值就低估吗
那现在这个已经涨回来了
涨回来之后看起来就有机会吧
当然如果你要问股价
这个又是另外一回事啊
就是说他
因为群创友达这种公司非常非常大
他们养的人非常非常多
那你目前先进封装那一点点产值
要去撑起这么大的公司是有困难
所以讲股价的话可能还是保守一点
网友说
曲伯觉得北方华创能做成像应用材料这类公司吗
你要听实话吗
答案是当然有可能
原因很简单
因为中国大陆的厂商
现在因为随时被美国卡脖子所以他们的客户不管跟国外厂商买得到买不到的东西都要求大陆要自己做国内要自己做
这就是人家有那个决心啊
台湾没有啊
北望华创做出来的东西
设备
一开始或许比不上应用材料公司
但是呢各位要知道只要客户愿意用愿意试
工程的东西就是慢慢调慢慢调就可以调出来
呃我记得好像是华为董事长任正非说过
他说这个
矽晶片是人造的不是神造的
只要是人造的就做出来
没有做不出来的理由
重点是你要给他机会测试
那这个进润式的生子外光亮产
为什么这么多人嘲讽啊
这个没有啊很正常啊
因为有些人不懂啊
我跟各位说啦
这个当然讲了会被网友骂
但是我还是要说实话去
我的特色就是说实话
会在那边嘲笑
大陆的半导体厂商的
那都不是业内的人
只要是业内的专业的都知道
大陆的半导体供应链
或者那些相关厂商
绝对不可以小看他
他是非常强劲的竞争对手
这个对台湾的厂商来说压力都很大
那每一次我只要在影片上讲这种话呢
大概就会有很多网友留言嘲讽啊
嘲讽的不是你哦是我
这个是简体制吗
你应该是大陆的网友
网友嘲讽的是我
但是各位要知道我从来不怕的
为什么你知道吗
因为被外行人嘲笑
这没有什么了不起
我比较在意的是内行人
怎么看
但是我跟各位说
我跟这么多业内的专家聊过
绝对没有一个专家在我的面前跟我说
可以小看大陆的厂商
没有一个我到现在没有遇过一个
每一個只要業內專家都跟我說
他們做的怎麼樣怎麼樣
然後我們的壓力很大
要怎麼怎麼才能夠跟他們競爭
很辛苦
我聽到的都是這種話
呃時間到了
不過我看一下
硬能利用高壓器
體除炮未來
大面積玻璃機板
散熱均勻壓力會遇到
當然會遇到瓶頸啊
他就要想辦法解決啊
他们开发1200W的两项式气能散热
可以跟艺能竞争吗
呃我认为
艺能的
〔此段辨識失敗，約 40:00 起〕